[Music]
arnold schwarzenegger was on 60 minutes
he's promoting his book he said some
crazy stuff arnold schwarzenegger said
you can't run from your mistakes you
have to confront them
yeah especially if they look exactly
like you and keep calling you dad
papa
papa
[Laughter]
papa you are my father
prove that you're my father
[Laughter]
sanity vice presidential uh vice
presidential the presidential debate is
on wednesday that's exciting i can feel
the energy
the hell was that
they don't care
interesting fun fact for you mitt romney
has been preparing for the debate by
debating a republican senator who's
playing the part of president obama
yeah
meanwhile president obama has been
preparing for romney by debating an atm
machine
it's true that's true
it's a very handsome atm very handsome
nice hair who has the new iphone anybody
here have the new iphone
get them boys well now we all know who
to mug
uh the other day uh a lot of people are
criticizing the new iphone yeah the
other day the ceo of apple apologized
for problems in the iphone's new map
program
yeah the ceo made the apology in a field
20 miles from where the press conference
was supposed to take place
and then deer wandered by
how was the map thing working for you
sir
that totally ruined my joke then
conan it's working quite well
it's the last time i asked someone in
the audience
sir back me up on this i can't it's
excellent
[Applause]
the vatican did you hear this the
vatican is getting complaints that
they're letting in too many drunken
tourists
people say they're letting in too many
drunken tourists yeah today the vatican
said those aren't tourists those are
priests
[Music]
it's catholic day here
this is interesting there's a new
internet search engine that's been
developed and it looks only for online
porn
yeah
yeah
it's called google
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy story in saudi arabia images of
women have been removed from all ikea
catalogs
yeah
of course in my experience most women
disappear the second they see a futon
from ikea
because you're
[Music]
you're in a dating scenario and they
come back to your apartment and they see
the futon
and they know that well you're not the
right fellow right
to have sex with right
anyone here have an ikea futon
any trouble hooking up with a lady
not at all conan
the upside of that joke was it just got
colder in here
[Laughter]
check this one out gang
i only say that when the one before it
bombed
hey gang
red lobster is coming out with a new
menu aimed primarily at people who don't
like seafood
red lobster yeah they were inspired by
the olive garden whose menu has always
been aimed at people who don't like
italian food
[Applause]
okay
yeah
wow
oh that was patronizing
good olive garden gag there o'brien
you're really swinging for the fences
now
hey oh
[Laughter]
hey it's being reported that target
target is requiring its employees to use
the word amazing as much as possible
if you work at target that's a rule you
have to say amazing as much as possible
yeah so now employees say things like
you're so fat it's amazing you're not at
walmart
[Applause]